we're just getting a red alert right now
that the Greek banks are extending their
holiday so it continues right there
waiting to see what the your what the
troika really is going to work out with
Greece and you know I want to just point
to one of the tweets you sent out
immediately after the referendum you
said result of referendum reminiscent of
the famous Network clip mad as hell and
I'm not going to take this anymore so is
this mad as hell right now Mohammed oh
yeah I mean by voting no 61 percent of
the voters in Greece made it very clear
that they want more understanding and
they want to be heard in Europe so they
are as mad as hell the fact that the
banks are going to remain shut even
longer is going to make them matter and
importantly it is making the economy
grind to a halt and that has
implications for the negotiations buddy
because it means first big weeks are
going to have to do more in terms of
reforms secondly the Europeans are going
to have to do more in terms of debt
reduction and in terms of immediate
financing so it complicates negotiations
that already were pretty complex and
they are very complex and it looks like
basically you know the economy is ground
to a halt as I mentioned we've extended
those bank holidays until Wednesday the
capital controls stay until then as well
me how much longer can the grease
economy just kind of stay still like
this not much longer I mean economic
activity is collapsing and with that tax
revenue is collapsing so it has a
vicious cycle to it the Greek banks can
open can only open on the two conditions
either the ECB increases its supports
through the ELA so the ECB gives more
money to the banks or alternatively you
get some new currency introduced that we
capitalizes the banks internally that's
the only two conditions under which the
banking system can we open and function
or even semi normally Mohamed a morning
if you can describe what a trade or an
asset class that is unlocked and unloved
right
now everyone's focused on Greece there
must be other things that are available
for investors but are being overshadowed
by events in Greece so if we continue
down this road it is a road that leads
us to Greg alert if that happens then
you should expect a spike in global risk
aversion and then you will get a
sell-off in virtually all markets at
that point good opportunities are going
to be created and those opportunities
really are named specific they rely on
the ability to generate lots of cash so
the internal resilience and they also
rely on a set of good fundamental so you
can see a number of u.s. stock names you
can see some peripheral bonds in Europe
you can see some emerging market to come
from some corporate bonds there's going
to be lots of selective opportunities
but not just yet we are still on a
pretty bumpy road and I'm afraid that
does still some some some nasty bumps
ahead we're literally right in the thick
of it and Mohamed you can't see this but
I'm Goomer right now we're showing
pictures of Vera focus this is not live
by the way these are just video of a
verra focus after his resignation and
you also you know you're quite active
obviously on Twitter lots of people
follow you including me you said naive
for creditors to celebrate verify his
resignation should grease compromise be
possible he would have helped to secure
required domestic buy in but what about
this new guy shackle Otis I mean are you
you do you feel that way still knowing
that he's now the finance minister so
he's been involved in negotiations and
and he has better working relationships
with Europe so so both these things are
positive very focus will be missed for
many reasons one of which is that had he
gotten to a deal and in particularly had
he gotten the debt reduction that Greece
needs from his creditors then he would
have been able to turn around and sell
it internally quite credibly now that's
going to be harder to do and remember
his statement going out was very
explicit he posted on his blogs the
reason why he was going out was because
the creditors not no longer wanted to
work with him and then he said quote
that that he was happy to where the
creditors loathing with pride he wears
the credit loading with pride so that's
quite it quite a strong statement were
you were you somewhat repelled by that
comment now wasn't at all repelled I
mean uh you know he has been pursuing a
point of view that has quite a bit of
economic logic behind it he did it
unconventionally right and that didn't
go down well in Europe but I think his
point is one that's supported by lots of
economists which is that Greece
fundamentally needs deeper debt
reduction Mohamed what would you be
whispering in the ear of Angela Merkel
today I would say to her that first
please don't follow what the Eurogroup
president said yesterday which was that
the outcome of the boat was regrettable
that's not the thing you should say to a
nation that vote is 61 percent in a free
election rather it's time to hear what
degrees the Greek people are saying and
then make one of two choices the first
choice is can this week government in
her opinion deliver on structure reforms
and more intelligent austerity yes or no
and secondly is she willing to push the
rest of Europe into providing a lot of
money up front and keep that reduction
if the answer to either of these things
is no then they all have to move to plan
B rather than prolonged what is a very
costly process remember i go back to
increase is basically shut down and the
longer that loss the harder it is to to
rehabilitate it once the conditions
allow for that